también matías yo siempre he creído que
es una profesión de
entrega si hay una cosa que la pandemia
puso a prueba es la entrega de ana
teresita sánchez maestra en san josé la
capital de costa rica hace un año las
escuelas cerraron y empezó a dictar las
lecciones desde casa preparación de
presentaciones vídeos las guías y la
revisión de cada una detallada mente
para indicarles a los estudiantes que
que estaba correcto que deben de
corregir que digamos de reforzar
entonces casi que fue el doble la
jornada de trabajo
con la virtualidad debe estar disponible
a toda hora
contestando dudas de estudiantes y
padres
además las mujeres en costa rica dedican
22 horas semanales más que los hombres a
las tareas del hogar la ministra de
educación considera que el excedente de
trabajo de las profesoras debe
corregirse lo más pronto posible creo
que la transición en el modelo de
educación combinada con la esperanza y
la meta propuesta a una presencialidad
ya de forma ordinaria va a ayudar a que
las maestras y las mujeres vuelvan
nuevamente a atender las
particularidades de sus quehaceres en
los horarios establecidos desde febrero
funciona el modelo combinado con
lecciones virtuales y algunos días
presenciales bajo un estricto protocolo
sanitario me siento alegre un poco
temerosa con todo esto del coi pero creo
que es un reto por afrontar vacunar a la
mayoría de docentes para fin de año es
la meta que algunas escuelas regresen
por completo a las aulas la aspiración y
aligerar las cargas una necesidad para
todas